make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
that they're never gonna know that I'm
recording in my underwear if I'm gonna
cord no I've only record would be
comfortable I'm not a human
I am a comic book fan we're two
distinctly types of people this is what
I put up with well I mean you know it's
that's what we were supposed to do
anyway right keep asking you knock down
my name I have been up since like six
o'clock in the morning and honestly I've
been working on this since the end of
Avengers in game right license really
came out and and what I've been trying
to do was find a way to bring the x-men
and the Fantastic Four in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the next two
phases and then in Phase six with
Avengers vs. x-men right like I've been
trying to find a way to do this and I
think I haven't figured out okay so
here's here's we talked about this in
the last video right like Avengers
endgame leaves off in such a way to
where there's so much world building
they can do the one of the feelings that
gives you is like they could stop making
Marvel movies now and then it would be
like so this was a fun journey and then
like that set and like we never get a
comic book movie from Marvel again we
know that's not gonna be the case
they're gonna make movies for ever
unless there's a big hand that's one of
these people don't understand with with
them basically owning all the rights to
all the characters except for like the
Incredible Hulk and then where the
Submariner who I think currently are
owned by Universal they can basically
make movies like forever like burn for
hundreds of years if they wanted to
because there's so much content to do
big story small stories all the time
stuff I mean like acts of vengeance can
basically be like like a whole series of
movies under itself those you guys don't
know acts Avengers was a story where
Loki went around and grabbed all the
supervillains and then basically pit
them against all the superheroes
um so think like old man Logan except it
didn't work and that's basically what
acts of vengeance is now
and my thought is okay this this really
begins in face five right because phase
four is kind of like it feels more like
the interim phase right you could set
things that but we talked about that
setting up two Secret Wars things like
that but really page four was more to
kind of like here's some movies that are
their their movies we always meant to
make and their sequels to movies that we
need to make because the first one was
so popular but like you could do phase
four and it doesn't really lead into
anything right like it was really go
anywhere it's just like this is
equivalent to like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe version of like an intermission
between between like major story arcs
which I wouldn't be surprised as they
did that later on down the line but this
picks up with phase five now face face
for will is supposed to last five years
right so it's like okay so five years
from now we start rolling the x-men over
to the MCU now I know that Feige and all
of them said it'll be at least ten years
but I'm kind of I'm jumping the gun and
saying we're gonna go ahead and like
we're gonna swing for five years and see
what happens so the first full movie we
get is Wolverine and and and there's the
reason for that is because it's
Wolverine right like everybody wants to
see Wolverine that's the thing like I
would argue that Wolverine would
probably be the most successful or at
least the the the highest-grossing
Marvel Cinematic Universe movie behind
Avengers infinity war and Avengers in
game I think it would even do better
than Black Panther because the one
question though the reason why people
are gonna go see it isn't necessarily
because it's Wolverine they're gonna see
how the Hugh Jackman replacement does
they want to see it like what like is
this guy gonna be as good as Hugh
Jackman so if for no other reason than
to like critique it and complain or to
love it
but everybody's gonna go see it because
Hugh Jackman is is Wolverine so it's
like you replace him with someone else
now I think it would do me even more
successful if they had Hugh Jackman
Rylan if they had Hugh Jackman in the
MCU I think it would do even better but
the basis behind this first movie
whatever the plot whatever the the the
main plot is that the takeaway from this
movie is that it basically gives us the
origin of mutants in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now you can build on
this with the Eternals film that's
coming out in phase four right like the
Eternals film can basically show the
Eternals coming to Earth in the early
days of humanity taking a subset called
The Wanderers basically like the missing
link between primate and man and and
then basically say like okay like one
one-third of the group was mother genes
are modified they became deviants which
are basic controls another third heather
genes modified baby
and the Eternals which are basically
angelic beams and then the third group
you know the the other third how their
genes modified and somewhere along the
line they will activate we just don't
know when and that sets the ground level
for like later on down on line however
many thousands of years later the
mutants will pop up what this does and
you can even tie this into the black
widow film right you could say okay wolf
rain was part of Team X which was
basically this covert you know wet work
black ops team that was ran by the CIA
and they were designed for like taking
out enemies and doing all kinds of crazy
things you can even tie it into the want
air if you want to holla but but
nonetheless you get tied into a whole
host of like modern-day events and like
Black Widow served alongside them or
like they worked alongside like a shield
like he literally had like a shield
group a shield attachment that went in
and shield did their own thing or a big
lever was they were designed to
basically be like a distraction so team
H could sneak in and sneak out nobody
would know they were there and like
Black Widow was the one who was like
talking with Team X saying here's what
we're gonna do you can you can tie those
things and Team X of course being like
rain and Sabretooth and so on and so
forth but then basically you say
somewhere along the line Wolverine is
taken and he's thrown into like weapons
plus or whatever the case says but like
when they're experimenting on him they
discover a gene that when it's activated
give them powers and then he basically
develops a healing factor and so that
leads into the origin of mutants of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because what
they do is they take that gene they
synthesize you know the the activation
process spread across the world
voila you've got the mutant population
that just kind of rises up seemingly out
of nowhere right so those are guys who
follow the Inhumans think terrigenesis
like the event of of in humanity like
like during infinity when the terrigen
bomb was detonated think of that except
apply the mutants and wolf rain if
though the catalysts not the detonation
of a Terrigen bond by life bolt when
Thanos was beating the hell out so from
there you you jump from from the
wolverine film the second movie you make
is New Avengers now New Avengers doesn't
really tie into anything per se Riley
doesn't really bring in the the x-men
any further than they already are you
might have a post-credits scene or
something like that what this does is it
helps to world build why don't we do
here with the New Avengers is I would
take the first story arc or Brian
Michael Bendis the round though the guys
don't know what the raft is the raft
actually laid the groundwork for Secret
Invasion later on but the raft was a
storyline were Elektra the Spider Man
villain was contracted to go into the
raft which was this super secret number
leaf secret prism but it was this prism
designed to hold like the worst of the
like the super-powered criminal
offenders and then in turn you took down
power to it and that allowed all of them
to escape and so the New Avengers rigged
new vendors basically formed in response
to that as a means to like track down
these various villains and bring them in
so at the time that comet came out the
New Avengers consisted of Captain
America Iron Man like I don't think
Mookie may be located as part of that I
don't remember I know he was there
during the raft event and he actually
ended up being taken over by purple man
who tried to get him to kill everyone um
it had spider-man it had rain it had a
handful of people here and there but it
was a whole new roster right like the
New Avengers the reason why this world
builds is because what you can do is you
can say some event takes place some
prison is broken into or whatever the
case is but all of these villains escape
and you introduce villains that didn't
exist before right like they were
captured and they were thrown into a
prison sometime between the movies and
so we never really saw them because they
were never a main plot or you can say
like this is what the new leaders have
been doing between the time that like
you know the the team formed at the end
of Avengers in game and the time they
exist now you could there's a lot of
things that you can do but you can add
in things like maybe we get a new Iron
Man you know maybe we like shang-chi
because you know we don't Shane Chi then
the master of martial arts is getting a
movie in phase four
so maybe Shane she joins the New
Avengers so you throw him on and we see
him more often what it does is it solves
the problem of trying to create a sequel
and it just throws him on to the New
Avengers team and that's really all the
exposure that he needs and gets the
alternative to that is to push shang-chi
on on Heroes for Hire but as far as I'm
aware miss unite and and all those
characters they all exist on the on the
Netflix side of things they don't exist
in the movies so I don't think there's
any real crossover there from there we
switch to the third film third film is
the Fantastic Four
now again we don't win it when it comes
to all the Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies in phase one they were all
basically origin stories introduction
films this is no different ah this the
team basically forms and it doesn't need
to be a huge drawn-out point of the film
right like we talked about that in black
panther 2 how you can have this sort of
lead-up you can do the legwork ahead of
time before the movie that introduces
the Fantastic Four and shows like Ares
in this going on the opening credits to
the film is like the opening credits to
the Incredible Hulk this story of how
the Fantastic Four became that the
and a support we got that in the
Incredible Hulk movie with Edward Norton
this story of how Bruce Banner became
the Hulk is covered in a two and a half
minute credit sequence and then the
movie picks up you do the exact same
thing here and then what winds up
happening is a team basically fights
against Doctor Doom now the reason why
this is important is because what this
does is it sets the stage for the
power-hungry nature of Doctor Doom we'll
come back to that why it matters here in
a minute but basically that like dr.
doom is this this being that just he
will always try to acquire absolute
power it's one of the things that hitman
established and it's Fantastic Four run
but it always kind of been a non running
theme in the Fantastic Four comics is
that Doctor Doom will always try to do
whatever it takes to gain absolute power
his thirst for that level of ability
that level of power is unquenchable
he'll never have enough all right from
there you switch over to the next movie
the fourth movie which is Deadpool
who cares what the plot is it's Deadpool
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe it'll
put butts in the seats now from here you
switch over to the fifth film the x-men
and this is this is this is going to be
cool because what the x-men does is
again
you basically have like the two and a
Half Men and intro sequence that
basically like like shows the x-men
forming whatever the case may be but the
result is that you basically have a team
faced off against magneto now it does
seem like a lot to do right like to
introduce the team to give us the basis
behind why the team exists to to
internally have magneto pop up explain
the whole backstory to him and then then
have the team faced off against him but
not really like it was like an Iron Man
they covered all that right like Tony
Stark went from a weapons manufacturer
who didn't care about anything but
making money to basically a superhero
over the span of two hours two and a
half hours so it's easily done like it's
not overly complicated um there is some
backstory there you have to explain with
Magneto but the overall gist the
backstory just needs to be that he's a
he's an extremist right like that's
really all he is he's like he was like
the Mutant Liberation Front before the
Mutant Liberation Front
so you basically see like that's it that
that's really all he is it's just
radical extremists who believes that
like people want to take out mutants or
whatever the case is and like operates
according and then so you just throw
that out there the team the team faces
off against it now the the one of the
other takeaways is that while magneto in
the x-men are introduced in the Mollison
universe because of the nature of
Magneto and because he's so extreme it
puts mutants on the radar of humanity in
a way that it wasn't there before
basically humanity starts to be mutants
as a credible threat and so what they
end up doing is they basically start
inducting and going to the process of
initiating project wide awake that's I
love project wide awake
I love project light away those guys who
don't know this was a joint venture
between like the NSA the FBI the CIA
like like what is it um it was oh my god
I forgot so many of the names now it was
Valerie Cooper the president's advisor I
think of like it was it was a whole host
of people like local and like like local
police state sheriff's office like every
single almost every single intelligence
and and police I guess law enforcement
organization in the country was all
basically tasked with finding a way to
containing control the mutant threat
don't break the Constitution but try to
find a way to do it like that's really
all it was and it was really really cool
because what it does is it sets the
stage for the federal government being
against the against the x-men why does
that matter we'll get around with that
when it comes to a vintage vs. x-men so
here we pick up with the final movie and
phase five black panther 3 doom war now
here's a cool thing about this black
panther black panther is you know we got
the first film it was resounding success
everybody loves black panther black
panther ii will be in phase four phase 5
given part 3 the reason why I say this
is do more is because will basically do
what they did with Captain America three
Civil War where it was technically an
Avengers movie but it was called a
Captain America film you the same thing
here
doom war was a story in Marvel Comics
where where Doctor Doom had come to the
realization that my brain ium had the
ability to amplify magical energy and so
what he did is he basically well through
some really really shady channels funded
a coup d'etat in Wakanda and the result
was that the I camera who it was it who
was it rose up but the result was that
this basically like grass grassroots
organization this grassroots political
group had all the funding they needed
from Doctor Doom like arms armament all
that kind of good stuff
they basically like rose up against
black panther they ousted him like he
was he was injured in the process which
resulted in Sheree taking over the
mantle of black panther and that's why
the table becomes king of the dead
during Hickman's Avengers of New
Avengers were era
3 Hickman's Fantastic Four run but
basically what is up happening
dr. doom basically sets up this Griffith
huge distraction and removes T'Challa
from from Wakanda what it does is that
because the challahs not there and
because he is a credible threat to dr.
doom
the result is that there's no one there
to really protect the vibranium dr. doom
sneaks in steals all the vibranium and
then leaves and then basically like
becomes like this super-powerful guy now
there were some cool things that went on
like the Panther got vast like there
were different tests to access the great
mound of Wakanda and one of them was
that you had to address the Panther God
bast and so we're we're Doctor Doom did
that like you stripped himself down
totally naked and and basically entered
into the spirit world and talked to you
I talked to bass if he failed the test
bats would have killed him because he
was basically powerless there but he
ended up telling bass that hey look like
I really want to make the world a better
place
it humanized dr. doom in a really really
cool way and the result is that bass
basically agreed and then let him take
all the vibranium now this matters
because what it would mean is that dr.
doom becomes this hugely powerful guy
and it's a way to kind of pay tribute to
one of the most popular villains in the
history of Marvel but what it also does
is it brings together the New Avengers
and the x-men and Fantastic Four because
they all have to basically be a part of
this conflict it's the only real way to
stop a guy with such extreme power but
one of the other really big takeaways
from this is it brings storm a black
panther together and so the result is
that now you have a relationship forming
between storm and black panther now
following this we go into Phase six now
this is where things get a little bit
dangerous here what I would do is I
would say okay for x-men 2 we do God
loves man kills now youuuu can do like
some modified version of it right like
Disney's not gonna make an x-men movie
that opens up with like two kids being
killed in a park and strung up no that's
that's not gonna happen
Disney's gonna be like not a chance like
that's that's thing that's never gonna
work but but you take the theme the
basis that remains the same but now it's
not really just the government that's
against against mutant population its
humanity now it's now I don't know if
Disney would be willing to take like the
nature of William Stryker right like
this radical fundamentalist Christian
who believes that God wants him to kill
movies like I don't know if they would
really take that because the United
States is like 80% Christian right so
like Disney's gonna piss off all the
Christians so I don't know if that's
really that's really what Disney wants
to do
if usually business really care Disney's
like is it gonna make money then do it
and like is it not gonna destroy our
rent then do it as long as it does not
go against the nature of the mouse
Disney doesn't really seem to care that
much and so doing godless man kills
would be awesome because what this does
is is in the aftermath of this or during
this conflict something happens
something big takes place like somebody
dies or some significant building is
destroyed something happens and the
result is that the government finally
starts moving against the mutants and
says like we have to take them out well
you've got Sam Wilson who is the new
Captain America Captain America is
intertwined with the government Sam
Wilson and the New Avengers say no no no
you guys stay hands off we've fought
with them before we're as close as
anybody ever gets for friends we will
bring them in that sets the stage with
the Avengers showing up to confront the
x-men now from there you're going to
Captain Marvel - who cares what the plot
to this movie is but the overall gist is
that Carol Danvers is leading sword
right like the sentient world
observation and response department this
is the organization that's like shield
except at monitors space but the reason
why this matters is because what it does
is it keeps her close to earth it keeps
her within within within talking
distance so that the Avengers can call
her in during the events of Avengers vs.
x-men and so from there you pick up with
Captain Britain now Captain Britain will
introduce the EDI the European Defense
Initiative and it'll expand the Marvel
Cinematic Universe those are guys who
don't know in Marvel Comics what you
have is you have the Avengers right like
the Avengers in the main Marvel Universe
then you have the EDI now technically
the EDI was ultimate universe and the
the Avengers in the Ultimate Universe
line of comics were called The Ultimates
but the principle still remains the same
the European Defense Initiative was
Europe's response to the Avengers and
basically trying to create their own
superhero team you had Captain Italy
Captain Britain Captain France so on and
so forth but what you do in this film
regardless what the plot is is you
basically tie in their relationship with
Colossus and so what you would do is you
would take the nature of the European
defense initiative in the Ultimate
Universe and then you would grab
Colossus from the main Marvel Universe
you would blend them together and throw
them into the MCU why does that matter
because in model comics in the main
Marvel Universe when the Avengers were
first formed Russia wanted to have their
own superhero team which later on became
known as the winter guard but what
Russia did is they went through and
basically kidnapped every single person
with superpowers that they could find
and then brought them in there and force
them to become part of the team
Colossus was supposed to be one of those
guys but Xavier showed up in the nick of
time right when classes was gonna be
captured
basically like shut down the mind of
everybody and then rock losses to the
x-men during giant-size x-men number one
that's how Colossus joins the x-men team
and so what you do is you grab that and
you throw it in the MCU and basically
say Colossus has friends in the EDI even
if he's part of the x-men because there
were people he grew up with or something
along those lines why does that matter
because from there we go from Captain
Britain into Avengers vs. x-men now how
this whole thing that this really kind
of builds on everything that we've seen
so far but if indeed vs. x-men this
takes place the EDI is called in by
Colossus to join the x-men against the
Avengers and so again I would do like
Avengers vs. x-men as two parts the
result it's is it is made of forth
mariah sent me a some of the texts that
it's made of for it may the force be
with you but uh but nonetheless you
basically have colossus that bolsters
the ranks of the x-men by calling in the
EDI from there the avengers call and
carol danvers to basically buster their
numbers in order to to you know can face
up against the x-men but the overall
gist of Avengers vs. x-men would be the
Avengers showing up saying hey look we
got to bring you guys down like you guys
have to come in like nothing Bad's gonna
happen to you but like you know we gotta
bring you guys on the plot I'm not a
hundred percent sure about it is kind of
thin um The Avengers are not x-factor
right like Max Factor was originally a
team that consisted of the original five
x-men that were launched by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby when that love when that line
of comics essentially ended that first
volume with Lewis and Walter Simonson
ended and the original five x been
rolled back into the main x-men team and
then we got gold and blue teams from
there like X Factor was relaunched as a
government-sanctioned superhero team and
so that basically led into the events of
life of like I want to say it was I
think was Valerie Cooper who was the
liaison originally and then Forge took
over and he became a liaison but
basically um you had like Valerie Cooper
who spoke to who ran the ran X Factor on
behalf of the federal government and
then after her you have four jewel and X
Factor on behalf of the federal
government but regardless of the
circumstance while the Avengers aren't
necessarily like a I don't know while
the Avengers aren't necessarily a
government superhero team you can offer
some explanation where the Avengers
realize like you know the mutants are
not going to come willingly and the
government tries to take them forcefully
it cuz leave like a huge conflict so
they show up there is
more or less like like humanitarians
like hay saying look we know we came
here because this is what the
government's gonna do that does not need
to happen just come in answer some
questions well get stuff sorted out in
the mutant say no and that leads to a
battle between the New Avengers and the
x-men again it's kind of thin and
there's definitely some work that we
need to be done there in order to really
really get it together but for the most
part in terms of leading up to Avengers
vs. x-men I think that works and I think
it actually comes together exceedingly
well so let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section I'm kind of
curious I love making videos like these
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section and this being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end and I will catch you all later
[Music]